tenemos aquí un rectángulo grande que
está dividido en otros cuatro
rectángulos ahora lo que yo quiero hacer
es expresar el área de este rectángulo
de dos formas distintas la primera como
la multiplicación de dos binomios y
después la quiero expresar como un
trinomio entonces pensemos un poquito en
esto por aquí sabemos que la altura de
este rectángulo morado es equis y
también sabemos que de aquí a acá mide
dos entonces toda esta altura de aquí va
a ser x más 2 así es que la altura de
todo el rectángulo es x + 2 pero ahora
queremos saber cuál es la base de este
rectángulo y cuánto mide de ancho y de
ancho pues tenemos que de aquí a acá es
x
y de aquí para acá es 3
entonces el ancho de este rectángulo
grande es x + 3 y así de fácil ya
expresé el área de este rectángulo como
el producto de dos binomios pero ahora
queremos expresarla como un trinomio y
para hacer eso lo que vamos a hacer es
dividir al área completa en las áreas de
estos rectángulos más pequeños
así es que cuál es el área de este
rectángulo morado de aquí pues sabemos
que su altura es x
y su base también es x por lo que su
área es x cuadrada x cuadrada y ahora
cuál es el área de este rectángulo
naranja pues su altura es esta misma
altura de aquí que es x y su base su
ancho es 3 entonces su área va a ser x x
3 o sea 3 x entonces el área de este
rectángulo es 3x y para obtener el área
total estamos sumando todas estas áreas
por lo que aquí vamos a sumar 3 x esta
expresión que llevamos aquí lo que
representa es toda esta área el área
morada más el área naranja y ahora
podemos seguir con el área de esta
región verde cuál va a ser el área de
este rectángulo pues la altura es 2 y el
ancho es x entonces si multiplicamos
ancho por altura nos queda 2
y lo podemos simplemente sumar por aquí
y finalmente el área de este rectángulo
gris pues la altura es 2 que esta altura
de aquí es 2 y su ancho es 3
entonces tiene un área de 6 porque 2 por
13-6 los 10 que sumamos en 6 por aquí y
aquí tú me puedes decir oye este no es
un trinomio tiene aquí cuatro términos
pero también nos podemos dar cuenta que
estos dos términos de enmedio se pueden
sumar si tenemos tres equis y le sumamos
dos equis lo que nos quedan son 5x por
lo que todo esto se simplifica en x
cuadrada más 5 x +
así es que tanto ésta como ésta son dos
formas diferentes de expresar el área de
este rectángulo grandote y por lo tanto
tienen que ser iguales lo cual tiene
mucho sentido porque si multiplicamos
estos dos binomios y después
simplificamos lo que nos va a quedar es
esto de aquí y de hecho lo podemos hacer
ahorita rápidamente multiplicamos la
equis por la equis y nos queda la equis
cuadrada después multiplicamos la equis
por el 3 y nos queda 3x luego
multiplicamos el 2 por la equis y nos
queda 2x y finalmente multiplicamos el 2
por el 3 y nos queda 6 y bueno para lo
que nos sirve en estos modelos de área
es para tener una representación visual
de la multiplicación de binomios y tal
vez nos sirve para entender x
qué hacemos la multiplicación de
binomios de la forma en la que la
hacemos también hay por ahí un vídeo en
el que usamos la propiedad distributiva
dos veces pero ésta nos da una
representación visual de porque
realmente tiene sentido que estas dos
cosas sean iguales